so evident I didn't have to say it this
week I I who look I don't know why
you're happy this week we please we have
an impeachment inquiry it's wait a
second liberals
listening in the inquiry women I get a
puppy we're just here to look
look I I have been hurt too many times
you know the Republicans are definitely
the party of rednecks but Democrats are
the party of blue balls I tell you I can
tell liberals are really excited about
this one you know why because I was
checking out the Halloween store in West
Hollywood the other day don't ask you
know what is flying off the shelf of the
sexy whistleblower costume look there is
a real chance we will know once and for
all if Trump did the things he openly
admits to doing well he did admit it
this week you know we saw a transcript
of the call that's at the center of this
big controversy with the Ukrainian
president where he asked a favor of the
Ukrainian president and this raises some
very serious questions like is there a
foreign country he hasn't asked to
interfere in our elections I mean it may
come to nothing I like I say I've been
down this road before but you know what
well now it feels good
feels like that moment when a parent
goes you know the timeouts aren't
working I'm gonna slap them just right
slap your kid I said but this one could
be different I mean P that raises the
you know people around the president are
scared because they look like they are
complicit I mean in the whistleblowers
complaint it says that up maybe 12 or
more White House staffers listened in on
the call and then some of them helped
hide the transcripts of the call in a
more private server remember that term
Trump's got treason on his computer like
most men have porn you know it's I got
to erase my browser history before Nancy
Pelosi gets and trumpet with this man
he's such a mental case every day he
says over and over that the phone quote
was a perfect call he said it a million
times perfect per ever had a lost for
word Donald Trump mean it's a perfect
call like he's the Simone biles I'm
talking on the phone
perfect he refers to hanging up as
nailing the dismount my question is if
it was such a perfect call why are you
behaving like a bed-wetter trying to
hurry up and wash the sheets
they they are so comically inept at
covering up the crimes that they are
committing the White House this is true
wrote two pages of talking points about
this as innocent people do and sent it
out to the Republicans in Congress but
also accidentally sent it to the
Democrats this is the political
equivalent of sending a dick pic to your
mom the centerpiece of this Rudy
Giuliani who is not a federal employee
you know he's an uber driver he's an
independent contractor he had the C's at
the center of all this pushing the Biden
conspiracy theory meeting with the
Ukrainians which explains Rudy's new
nickname America's traitor
Rudy came back from Eastern Europe and
Trump said where's the dirt and he he
said in my coffin why but he is so out
of control did you see this say that
this is true he said we heard the tape
he was talking to a reporter he said it
is impossible the whistleblower it's a
hero and I'm not I will be the hero and
this is over I will be the hero and if a
wardens of a Scooby doing those meddling
kids I'd be the really the Republicans
really they look desperate they do did
you see this at at the whistleblower
hearing this week Devon Nunez from
hearing here in California but it
claimed the Democrats tried to obtain
nude photos of Donald Trump and in the
picture you can tell it is Trump's penis
because he drew it bigger with a sharpie
you